supongamos que tenemos un par de
funciones que son inversas entre sí así
que tengo por acá a fx y también voy a
tener a g de la cual será la inversa de
fx
por lo tanto fx también será la inversa
de g de x y xi la noción de función
inversa es completamente desconocida te
encargo que antes de ver este vídeo
repase los vídeos sobre la función
inversa en khan academy ahora la idea
principal de una función inversa es que
si tomas
de fx o puedes decir que si tomas la
función inversa df de x bueno obtienes x
y esto sale de la idea de que es una
función inversa si este es x entonces la
función f mapea esta x a un cierto valor
f x y ahora la función g o f inversa lo
que hace es tomar f x y mapear la de
regreso a x así que aquí tengo a efe
inversa que como ya dijimos es lo mismo
que cede x así que este fue un pequeño
repaso de funciones inversas pero ahora
vamos a aplicar un poco de cálculo a
todo esto y vamos a usar la regla de la
cadena y estoy seguro de que vamos a
obtener un resultado muy importante lo
que voy a hacer es tomar la derivada de
ambos lados de esta ecuación por lo
tanto voy a aplicar el operador derivada
de ambos lados y que voy a obtener
bueno del lado izquierdo tenemos que
aplicar la regla de la cadena
me quedaría la derivada de g con
respecto a efe y tendría que prima de ft
x ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por la
derivada de f con respecto a
entonces esto por efe prima de equis y
bueno esto va a ser igual a que tengo la
derivada con respecto a x de x eso es
simplemente 1 y aquí es donde tenemos
nuestro resultado importante todo lo que
hemos hecho es simplemente aplicar lo
que conocemos sobre funciones inversas y
después usamos la regla de la cadena
para poder tomar la derivada y si ahora
dividimos todo entre g prima de fx que
vamos a obtener bueno vamos a obtener
una relación entre la derivada de una
función y la derivada de su función
inversa obtendríamos que f prima de x es
igual a 1 entre g prima de fx y esto es
bastante elegante porque si sabes la
derivada de una función entonces puedes
encontrar la derivada de la función
inversa
además podemos ver que esto es cierto
tomando ejemplos de algunas funciones
por ejemplo si decimos que fx es igual a
a la x entonces gtx es igual a am bueno
a la función inversa de fx y cuál es la
inversa de ea la x una forma de verlo es
que si tenemos que igualar al x y
queremos encontrar su inversa primero
cambiamos las variables y obtengo que x
es igual a e al aiem y si aplicamos el
logaritmo natural de ambos lados obtengo
que el logaritmo natural de x es igual a
ye así que la inversa de ea la x es el
lugar y donato uralde x y una vez más es
simplemente un repaso de funciones
inversas recuerdan si esto te parece
desconocido revisa el contenido sobre
funciones inversas en khan academy
entonces gdx es igual al logaritmo
natural de x
ahora veamos si esto es cierto para
estas dos funciones a que sería igual f
prima de x
bueno este es uno de los resultados más
bellos del cálculo ya que sabemos que la
derivada de la x es la equis y en otros
vídeos ya hemos visto que la derivada
del logaritmo natural de x es 1 / x así
que veamos qué dice esta expresión tengo
que ir a la x debe de ser igual a 1 / g
prima de fx ok eso me quedaría como 1
entre 1
/ efe de x que es la equis y bueno es
esto cierto pues sí lo es
1 entre 1 entre a la x es simplemente a
la x así que todo funciona y bueno como
ambas son funciones inversas puedes ir
en el otro sentido y decir que he prima
de x esto es 1
/ efe prima deje de x porque son
inversas entre sí de todo esto lo
importante es que ya podemos encontrar
la derivada de la función
inversa usando esta expresión así que
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo hasta
pronto